i feel like you've matured a lot
in the last couple of years as far as
maybe
keeping yourself out of unnecessary
situations that might bring unnecessary
[ __ ] around do you feel the same way
oh yeah i got two daughters now you know
what i'm saying and
i ain't only that [ __ ] just
tired of that street [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying get burnt out bro that's just
tiring bro stressful [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you
don't have to keep like looking over
your shoulder everyday all right it's
philly that [ __ ] bad right now bro
that's just super super big like we
probably got like
how many mergers we have right now tyler
and philly
500 over 500 overlapping it's five to
six months
it's been mostly females getting killed
by [ __ ] like literally what some weird
[ __ ] [ __ ] is like domestic violence [ __ ]
a lot of it been the domestic violence a
lot of been like [ __ ] like [ __ ]
just killing [ __ ] i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is like i seen some [ __ ]
where somebody thought it was like
i don't want to be putting this [ __ ] out
there so i ain't even gonna say [ __ ] you
i talk about you right
right that should be weird though bro
was is is interesting too because like
we just we just lost dolph
and dolph was you know i had a great
relationship with dolph he was a great
guy but
we keep seeing artists losing their life
in their hometown
right wicked um
happened happened in nipsey happened to
x um
i feel like it's almost necessary to
kind of remove yourself out of
your own environment for your own good
really for your own livelihood you know
what i'm saying
got to
it'd be like people love you the most in
your city but but they hate you the most
there too
like you got some [ __ ] that just
really likes
i see i remember that [ __ ] when he was
broke now he think he uh
like [ __ ] we just don't want to see
you win for some reason some people got
that crab in the barrel mentality like
[ __ ] you i'm stuck you got to be stuck
with me type [ __ ] like on someone
when you see like a situation with dolph
you know or nip does it help does it
kind of
change the way you move hell yeah before
you didn't
the nipsey [ __ ] was crazy i think the
first journal for me though was like
looks like somebody from pittsburgh or
some [ __ ] oh um
jose was it the guapo the guy who died
he died the same day as nip yeah yeah he
died the same day it was the same day
damn so yeah i heard about that first
and i'm like damn this [ __ ] like
he was close to philly in pittsburgh's
night right there yeah it's far but like
we on the same type of [ __ ] kind of like
you know what i'm saying like i'm like
damn that was a bad joke for the city
you know what i'm saying the pittsburgh
i'm like that [ __ ] was still in the
trenches he's kind of just like me like
that was like an eye-opening like thing
i need to
get away from you it is just in general
i feel like crazy right now especially i
mean we both live here in la and la is
[ __ ]
wild
crazy
there's some grand theft auto [ __ ] going
on right now [ __ ] bro you seen that [ __ ]
with a [ __ ] just walked up on the
restaurant
yeah
well first of all
i'll be in the valley so
me and my wife keep it super low key but
i tell my wife when we go out to eat i'm
like leave your she got a big-ass
wedding ring i'm like leave that [ __ ] at
the crib i don't even want to kill you
though bro you don't want unless you're
gonna move around with security you
don't want to have to do that where did
you get the time you go out a hundred
percent feel me like that should be ass
bro
i feel you people are targets out here
and especially
a couple times you feel me like i ain't
gonna lie that [ __ ] don't never work for
me i'll be too on point like i'm from
the same [ __ ] y'all trying to do i
didn't get to see you feel me like i
don't get ready for that kind of [ __ ]
yeah yeah i'll be on it
that's fair that's fair i think like a
lot of people need to understand when
they come to l.a
don't think this is a joke well also
it's hollywood yeah but like yo man
leave your [ __ ] jewelry in the hotel
room or just leave it at home like
there's no reason for you to move around
with a hundred thousand dollars worth of
if you're gonna do that [ __ ] bro be safe
be safe get some security yeah
like i ain't gonna sit here and say
security is like a endo be a [ __ ] ain't
gonna try you but it's thick twice don't
think twice about trying you yeah hell
yeah a hundred percent it just makes
sense you know it does man